creating a safe work environment is more
important than ever not only can it help
protect workers from injury and illness
but it can raise morale reduce
absenteeism and turnover and improve
overall productivity
however creating a working environment
where employees both are safe and feel
safe can be challenging
for instance proper safety protocols and
procedures have to be clear
accessible and easy for everyone to
follow appropriate feedback channels
must be in place
so safety concerns can be reported and
addressed in a short amount of time
safety documentation and procedures have
to be meticulously tracked stored and
protected
this can be a huge undertaking but
luckily google cloud is here to help
by leveraging google cloud technologies
organizations can create a workplace
that is more productive
safer and happier let's see how an
organization could use these products to
better identify and address their safety
issues
meet ashley ashley leads the safety team
at a growing manufacturing company
although they don't have any coding
experience hasley and her team have
created a suite of safety apps using app
sheet
google cloud's no-code app development
platform each of their employees and
contractors are able to download these
apps and access them at any time on
their mobile devices
one day han who works in the
manufacturing facility slips and almost
falls while walking up the stairs
outside their building
instead of ignoring the incident han
knows that there's an easy way to report
any risk he notices he's able to open up
his safety risk reporting app and fill
out a form detailing the safety risk
including the risk level
details
picture and even annotations
once he completes the form ashley who's
on the safety board
is immediately notified of the issue
she's able to open the report
read through the details and claim the
ticket
ashley wants to understand the situation
better so she sets up a meeting to talk
to han
they join a google meet video call so
they can talk face to face
her team decides they would like to hire
a contractor to install railings along
both sides of the stairs
they work with the management legal and
finance teams in real time to update and
finalize the contract
back in the app asi is able to document
the steps taken to address this risk
once the contractor is finished
installing the railings ask is able to
close the ticket by selecting resolve
this is just one example of the many
types of safety apps you could build
using these google cloud solutions
creating applications such as these can
take days or weeks not months or years
to build
allowing businesses to work safer faster
and better
to learn more and to access this and
other app templates click on the link
below
[Music]
you